how fundamental has the delivery team
been for you to get to where you are now
do you think yeah super important like
I've always said it's like the engine
room when the delivery team's firing it
frees up the 360 guys just to sort of
focus on their own marketing so all the
other stuff that they're generating on
the side should get picked up by
delivering I think the upskilling of a
delivery team makes an enormous
difference to the quality of service
you're able to give your clients because
you're able to like stick to that
five-day turnaround on CVS and there are
multiple points of contacts for clients
so if someone's on holiday or they're
already dealing with the delivery
consultant so there's two points of
contacts and stuff for someone to reach
out to so I think it's super important